my name is julie i am the director at
lux bag spa here at lux bag spa we
restore luxury designer handbags i'm
going to show you how we are going to
restore this very loved chanel handbag
this is a chanel classic flap and it's
about 12 to 15 years old a bag like this
the state that it's in it would be about
fifteen hundred dollars after the
restoration it could go to about five or
six thousand usd the bag definitely
needs a really good clean we're gonna do
a full coloration as well as take the
strap apart and make sure we're
polishing all of the hardware
this bag looks to have many years of
dirt and grime build up on it
first we're gonna go ahead and clean the
exterior of the bag just with a gentle
mild leather cleaner using a horsehair
brush this really helps get into the
leather and the cracks of where the
stitching is so we're able to really get
a deep clean without hurting any of the
exterior leather
i'm going to go in now with our leather
moisturizing cream i want to use this
actually before i start pigmenting the
back because i don't want the bag to
crack so i will just let this sit on for
a little bit
it has avocado oil in it so it will
bring back a lot of its original
moisture
now we've unraveled the entire chain and
the reason that we're doing this is
because we want to polish the hardware
separately from it being attached to the
leather of the chain
we're going to go in with the same
leather cleaning solution that we did
for the exterior of the bag and we're
going to also use the gentle horse hair
brush
now that we've finished cleaning i'm
going to go in with a acetone based
leather primer so we want to take off
even more pigment if we are able to
just to make sure that the bag is
prepped and ready for the coloration
looking in the interior you can see that
there is some of the original color
still in here so this is actually what
we're going to be color matching in the
bag
i'm going to go in with a small angled
brush just so i have more control over
concealing these areas i like to think
of the bags as how you would do your
makeup you want to conceal the darker
spots first before applying the rest of
the pigment this just makes it more
cohesive throughout and makes the bag
look like it did as the original
i'm switching now to a larger paintbrush
when we're doing the full exterior
coloration this just helps me cover more
surface area of the bag and really get
into those grooves
i am painting this bag by hand because i
find i have a lot more control
i'm going to apply filler to this area
here to make it smooth on this interior
flap
after the filler is completely dry we
want to go in with a sander we just want
to make sure that everything is level
and just looks natural on this flap
as you can see here i have left the
panel surrounding the cc without any
pigment and you can already see the
color difference between the two but the
reason we're doing this is because we
don't want the silver polish to destroy
or deteriorate any of the pigment that
we're going to put on now since it is
quite a harsh chemical so i go into all
the hardware with a q-tip just dipping
it into the silver polish and rubbing
away any tarnish or dirt that has
collected over the years
i'm going in with an angled brush that i
also used for concealing this bag
i just want to be a little bit more
precise with
painting around the cc and if i got any
pigment on the cc it doesn't really
matter i'm able to take a q-tip and wipe
that right off but i try and keep it as
clean as possible
now i'm going to go in with the second
layer and i'm doing this a little bit
thinner than the one prior
now we're going to look at doing
coloration on the strap here we're going
to go in and conceal the dark marks just
like we did on the exterior of the full
bag and then go in and paint the
entirety of the strap
even though we did polish the entirety
of this chain there is a few spots that
we want to resell our plate for these
spots here we will use our
silver plating tool which we dip into a
solution and with electromagnets it
actually puts silver back onto where
it's scratched off or tarnished off over
time
now that the strap is completely dry
we're going to weave it back together
when doing this we want to make sure
that the strap is completely straight
and if it isn't then your chanel bag is
going to be turning in a whole bunch of
different directions so this is a really
important step
using the same leather solution that we
did on the exterior i'm going to go in
with a horse hair brush and clean the
inside here
luckily we were able to get the interior
quite clean so this won't have to be
repigmented now we're going to apply our
top coat for this particular bag i chose
a matte topcoat and this actually will
lock in all the pigment that we
previously put on
i am super excited with how this
restoration turned out and i'm so
excited to see how the client likes it
when she receives her bag
[Music]